dna molecules
inside a confined environment just like
your headphones inside your backpack
will tend to tie knots there is a
theorem due to
the width summoners and jana yanandiau
that says that the knot in probability
goes to one as the length of the chain
goes to infinity in r3 so if you have a
very long cable it doesn't need to be a
complicated knot but eventually will
knot itself so you have such long
molecules
inside such small environments
it is to be expected that these
molecules will have some topological
complexity now we do not know
if
there is spontaneous nodding
we can anticipate there is
and we do not know if there is
spontaneous nodding is it important
for the cell we don't know that we know
that the cell typically does not like
topological entanglement so the cell has
an army of enzymes that the moment they
see a knot they'll come here they say oh
look there's a knot here okay we need to
break it they open they break they
transport
one strand through the brake and they
reseal the brake and when they do that
they are not the knot so these are
little pacmans that go around the cell
they are called type two to poison races
and they will just break the chain
transport another strand reseal the
chain and remove the topological
complexity hypotopoisomerases are
enzymes that are
ubiquitous they have been found in every
possible organism i mean from archaea to
humans
and they are essential to life
meaning
if the type totopi summaries in the cell
doesn't work the cell dies so they are
wonderful targets for antibiotic drugs
for example so there is a
a big family of drugs called
fluoroquinolones
you may have heard of cyprofloxacin
used for to treat bacterial
like urinary tract infections or
sometimes ear infections
what that drug will do is it will target
the type 2 topoisomerase in the
bacterium that is making you sick and
all those bacteria when the type 2
topoisomerase stops working these
bacteria will have an accumulation
of
interlinked dna not knotted but
interlinked dna and that accumulation of
topology will kill the bacteria so let's
assume this is
a dna molecule that is not helical yet
okay so now let's make it into a helix
it has to be a right-handed helix and i
need to twist this an even number of
times because otherwise when i close it
i would get a mobius band and that's not
what i want so now i'm going to close
this chain
right here so this is this isn't a human
this is not human dna then no let's
assume this is either one of those loops
or is a circular dna molecule that could
be a bacterial genome or it could be
just a naturally occurring plasmid
and this coil is just a natural coil
from the double helix and here i just
put two of those turns to make it
simpler
but there's many more turns
and now these scissors are the enzymes
that are going to start dna replication
so the circle if we assume that this is
a bacterial
dna there will be an origin of
replication replication will go
bi-directionally there will be first
enzymes called helicases that will
unwind the dna so they will break the
hydrogen bonds and open up the two
strands so unwind dna and we can mimic
that by just
cutting
and you can imagine another pair of
scissors going in the other direction
okay replication is done now we went
from one circle
one circular dna molecule to two
circular dna molecules well look what
the problem is
we have a topological problem right here
what's going on there they know they're
together
they're interlinked so they are two
independent circles each one of them has
exactly the same genetic code
but these two circles are interlinked so
now if each new cell wants to inherit
one circle they will pull
if they pull they will break if dna
breaks that's a very bad that's very bad
news for yourself
or very gently an enzyme called type two
topoisomerase the old friend will come
here
will break very gently will transport
one chain through the break and reseal
the break
and then i says am i done oh i'm not
done okay then i need to
break again okay i'm going to break
again transport reseal okay now i'm done
now i'm done now each one of these new
chromosomes can segregate to a new
daughter cell and cell division can
happen so this is a problem when type 2
topoisomerases don't work then the newly
replicated chromosomes are interlinked
and there's nothing you can do about
them and that interlinking will
eventually kill the bacterial cells
and this happens every time the dna is
replicating every time you go through
replication the dna is interlinked why
because dna is a helix
that's the reason it's a very simple
mathematical reason dna is a helix
so
when you cut it through the center
if it's circular and you cut it through
the center
these crossings
will become linked interlinks between
two chains
chromosomes that look like noodles but
they occupy distinct territories within
the cell nucleus and then you're looking
here well the question is is there
organization here